cette julian qu'elle je ne ferai pas
l'injure d'une présentation
téléspectateurs d'antenne 2 vous venez
de faire paraître je suis françois
fillon aux éditions d'un noël c'est
votre peau est préféré lyon oui
absolument je suis content d'avoir
retrouvé la trace de ses écrits en prose
mais c'est mon nom pourrait être prêté
mais peut être préféré mais comme vous
vous substituer à lui il parle à la
première personne je sais bien vous
allez nous dire vous avez trouvé le
manuscrit dans un grenier reviennent du
temps oui on gagne du temps mais on va y
aller donc je me méfiais de toi-même
donc
vous l'aimez au point de vous substituer
à lui ne seront pas charitable de la
marne puis je laime ave c pour être
assez fou pour prendre la plume avec
beaucoup de distance et d'humidité mais
avec une envie folle de vous mettre à sa
place
oui oui mais comment pouvez vous aimez
villon plus que c'était un immense poète
bien sûr mais un menteur un délateur un
voleur peut-être même un assassin est ce
que j'ai appris aux mêmes ici quelques
années que si on n'est pas hélas menteur
délateur grâce aux délateurs qui est
insupportable il a été mes mentors on ne
peut pas être libre dans le monde
constitué par les hommes donc je pense
que c'est pour ça que j'avais envie de
le retrouver comme moi ce siècle là on
pouvait on savait déjà
on a appris parce que c'est moins
douloureux maintenant on a appris qu'il
fallait mentir aux puissances jamais
mentir aux humbles si on voulait
conserver un minimum de liberté
vous avez menti aux puissants sinon
c'est parce que je ne savais pas encore
mais je vous promets action nommée
quelque part je le ferai ah bon mais
parce que j'ai pris du métier même juste
un petit peu tard et c'est pour ça que
je dis est le patron d'antenne 2 vous ne
manquez pas aux puissants je pense je
pense que j'ai commencé vers la fin et
c'est trop tard pour nous sauver
enfin ce n'est pas ce que vous seulement
c'est un aspect que vous aimez d'environ
qu'est ce qui me plaît dans l'homme
millions ne peut être fillon non ce qui
me plaît dans le poète vivant d'abord
c'est une oeuvre tellement essentiel et
petit ya 3000 vert en tout il ya quelque
part un projet de roman qui n'a pas
abouti donc j'ai voulu un peu aidé les
choses
ce qui me plaît c'est que cet homme est
au carrefour du moment où le
l'imaginaire et le réel peuvent
cohabiter ou le convenu et peut être
refusé or nous vivons à mon sens à mon
avis dans le convenu absolue donc c'est
le seul moment c'est un moment de tous
ceux qui se sont levés en font ce qu on
en compte que depuis que j'ai quitté les
entourent des pouvoirs approximatif
provisoire est éphémère g j'ai trouvé
j'ai en lui envie de faire des livres
comme le maître danger celui ci faire de
gens pour le mettre dans onze essais
question qu'il savait qu'il fallait
marcher pour ne pas être captif que des
conseillers des pendules des monnaies
exact
east l'homme devenait à l'animal le plus
civilisé certes mais le plus soumis de
la création donc révolte de celle de
françois villon et quelqu'un l'a
frasques et à mon avis c'est de tous
bien accueilli débouté de chacun
l'impossibilité à l'homme libre qui
n'est pas toujours confortable mais mam
de dalé d'un univers dans l'autre c'est
cette quête qui m'a semblé moderne cette
espèce de désespoir d'aujourd'hui qui
m'a amené à me plonger depuis des années
dans françois ville le 6 janvier 14 163
il a été banni de paris et ensuite on
perd sa trace
on ne sait pas c'est un coup de chance
parce que je veux dire il ya eu
plusieurs fins possibles imaginables par
les plus grands écrivains et celles qui
m'avaient la plus émue à l'époque
c'était celle de francis carco parce
qu'elle elle ressemble bien à francis
carco qui imaginaient que l'affreux
colonnes cayeux on dire aujourd'hui je
ne sais pas si c'est l'homme le duo
l'homme le criminel notoire en face à
quelqu'un qui ferait peur comme
l'instinct de mort de mesrine six
piliers et que cet homme connaît mme
cayeux
pourchassé entouré des gens du gué dans
une cabane dans les bois dans les bois
sous la neige était autour d'un feu et
bill on se réfugier là perclus les
jambes brisées par la torture et que les
colin lui disais non je t'en veux pas
d'avoir trahi je ne t'en veux de rien et
dû prêter son manteau pour qu'il s'en
aille
et puis l'on sortait avec le manteau de
colin et les gens qui attendaient
croyant que c'était colin le tuer
pendant collin sont allés dans la neige
je crois que c'est ce malheur permanent
de la truffe heures on aurait dit à
l'époque
et à côté de ça d'un homme qui a tous
voulu avoir il a voulu être aimé des
femmes il a même voulu en vivre et ça ne
va pas réussi tout ce qu'il a tenté
plaire dans les salons il sait bien puis
de passer pour un indicateur peut être
hélas les collectives et quand il a
voulu avoir le sacrement du son qui lui
semble elle peut être après le meurtre
de serment ajoutent ils ont l'accident
d'hier est il de serre moi tu es bien il
a il a abouti à la cour des miracles et
là encore il faisait pas le poids il a
fait le poids nulle part sauf au
creusement point we be il était il était
de la coquille comme comme d'autres
humilité la coquille comme des écrivains
d'aujourd'hui sondés sont des truands je
veux dire c'est à dire plus en
littérature que dans leur vie
mais si les gens oui mais le fait qu'il
fut peut être ça ajoutait à sa renommée
ou au contraire qu'on en ricaner non on
en rit connaît quand on n'avait pas de
goût on on y prenait plaisir content on
avait collé le maître queux quillard qui
est un effroyable bandits
sourit de lui oui parce que oui oui mais
simplement parce que pour lui un poète
et quand même quelqu'un qui n'entrave
pas la langue de l'arrco qui l'a apprise
ensuite il a fait toutes ces balades en
jargon
mais c'est surtout quelqu'un qui
fréquentent les puissants perd son temps
à des balivernes qui sont de manier la
langue alors qu'il ya du caire de
l'argent à prendre partout et des filles
partout donc ça lui semble une perte de
temps que vous nous présentez un
françois villon qui est je remarque vous
dites villes ont un oui c'est que on se
bat comme pour beaucoup d'autres noms
propres
visionnaire ou gabillon non parce que je
pense que j'en discutais avec jacques
laurent il me disait écoute ça dépend du
professeur de français qu'on a eu à bon
je crois que ça dépend essentiellement
de l'accord moi j'essaie de rien pas
très entendu c'est débile ont donc j'ai
suivi d'autres villes en vain pour milan
le on le voit là donc il est à la fois
victime du prévôt et puis ou de
l'accueil qui est pourtant pas qui est
incontestablement mobilier design en mai
dans la filiation avec le poète né
létard vérifier où est certainement bon
mais simplement on le voyait la victime
de l'autre parce qu'ils organisent le
rapt d'un trésor dans l'église la mairie
de bayeux mais à lille srd à pau à la
fois aux forces de police et puis mais
comme vous l'avez vu dans le codicille
il a trompé tout il a trompé tout le
monde mais je voulais que quelque part
la poésie elle vous le préférez trompé
par tout le monde ou trompant tout le
monde je le préfère écrivant aux forces
de police puisqu'il écrit ses mémoires
en sachant un voulons qu'elle soit qu'il
soit l'une pas le prévôt de paris donc
là je l'aï les victimes dans toute cette
partie de son récit dans la dernière
comme le codicille dans qu'il a souvent
employé quand procédés littéraires
alors il dit la vérité et de laïcs
disparaît pour essayer d'aller retrouver
le caire enfin l'argent de 13h du petit
jésus
y arrivera t je crains que non le piége
mahométans une invention de vous
injectez inventant qu'on a partagé avec
une personne qui se trouve dans la salle
comme dirait l'autre
qui est jean héritier qui a fait des
nokia vérifier les les textes ça nous a
semblé y en avait nous avons rajouté les
choses qui nous ont amusé ou fait
plaisir qu'est ce que vous préférez la
fin
françois villon trompant les autres tous
trompés par tout le monde le claude
pichois je crois que je préfère françois
weill en trompant les comparaisons merci
beaucoup aux noms de la poésie
oui moi je suis très frappé que la
cheville n'est pas du tout pas du tout à
l'heure il a dit qu'il aimerait être
françois villon et ce souhait m'étonne
un peu parce que ce qui m'a frappé mois
dans le livre c'est toute la relation à
l'anatomie le corps de cet homme très
nette qui meurent mène peut l'être
oui mais il ya en même temps de temps va
durer parce qu'il ya le soleil a le
corps des femmes dont il jouit ou
tentent de jouir et puis il ya son corps
à lui qui ne cesse d'être torturés hélas
pas laquelle à la mort constant vous en
fait quand même un personnage que tout
même qu'être est déchirant mais je
pourrais fait torturer vraiment retenu
il était donc a subi les brodequins les
brodequins oui la main la dure prison de
marg alors gelé
je pense que deux ou trois choses m'ont
servi d'abord la prison que j'ai connu
pendant l'occupation
l'annnonce de ma mort programmée dont
font des choses qui la connaissance de
la solitude dans les cellules la
fraternité avec les rats ou les insectes
le bruit des guichetiers vient en dehors
de cela le fait que mon père avait voulu
lorsque j'étais à la fac de lettres de
paris avait justement la guerre j'en
remercie
là où il est la brume je travaille la
nuit et que je travaille avec lui aux
halles où il était comme et génère donc
ça veut dire que rien ne pouvait donner
autant l'idée de ce monde de françois
villon pu les halles de paris avant
l'heure
de tranmere oui mais vous le montrez un
françois villon qui déteste les hommes
et qui aime les femmes
il ya un portrait superbe d'une dame de
bruges qui s'appelle magdalene mais elle
les hommes parce que ou qu'il tourne son
regard il est trompé mais écoutez je
pense je pense ans sans vouloir
généraliser que faure l'amitié qui était
celle pour régner de montigny qu'il
idéalise ou qu'il veut mot qui veut vif
quand ils devaient mort ce qui ne veut
pas le perdre l'amitié
il pense qu'une place ses espérances
dans les absences ou dans des modes donc
régner mans donc il veut tout donner a
régné parce qu'il aurait souhaité ne
jamais être trompés et magal est une
seule créature de ses mémoires qu'il
soit complètement inventés qui n'ait
jamais connues dont ils placent l'amour
et l'amitié qui sont probablement les
deux choses essentielles de sa vie à
part la poésie avec beaucoup plus de
garanties demandées par des gens qui
n'existent pas oui à ce qui ce qui est
bien fait que vous arrivez à introduire
les des poèmes fameux de françois villon
à l'intérieur de ses mémoires apocryphe
et tangeantant j'ai fait un vrai un
verre ou deux pour m'amuser ce qu'on dit
c'est vraiment oui beaucoup plus mobile
en acceptant la connaissez des verts
françois villon parker on va là bas tout
le monde si on parte quelques-uns alors
allez-y dicte moi ou non aucun pays
n'est flora la belle romaine harkis
piazzetta isc et puis sa cousine
germaine écho par l'encan bruit quand on
mène je suis les rivières ou 6 et ce
tant aux beautés autre plus humaine mais
où sont les neiges d'antan est
incontestablement un meilleur poète que
ce sens si ce n'est à faire de la promo
et moi alors sur ses mémoires un peu
crif s'est presque 1 re ce parce qu'un
polar parce qu'effectivement on suit on
sait pas s'il va y ait en réchapper ou
pas et avec donc de deux fins mais moi à
mon avis la réussite du livre c'est le
langage
bien entendu c'est ça qui donne sa
couleur sa patine et ça je sais pas ça
cher
au livre alors l'offre dû travailler
beaucoup pour trouver une sorte de
musique de l'est près mais ça et ça je
veux dire la seule chose que j'ai eu
tant le faire avant que la guerre
n'éclate la gt se préparait une licence
en littérature mais il va aller j'avais
toujours trouvé depuis cette époque où
les mots je prends un des exemples je
veux dire par là que le mot qui était un
véhicule qui a vu sa valeur absolue et
qui n'avait qu'un même sens pour tous je
prends un exemple dans le sud dans le
languedoc le mot mazel annick et un
petit marc petit demeure rurale isolée
tant qu'il ya eu les atrocités des
guerres de religion et qu'on a fait de
ces petits mas isolés laisser véritable
andouille étal de boucherie vient le mot
n'a plus servi qu'à dire étal de
boucherie société je crois que l'homme
moderne et le mot l'homme deux parties
l'homme politique l'homme des métiers
des pas des métiers artisanaux invente
un langage pour que les mots ne veulent
rien dirent qu'ils ne compromettent les
mots compromettez à l'époque j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
faits pour ne plus comprendre de raymond
castans vous avez aimé seymour j'aime ça
donne en résulte le langage le langage
le langage des démos et vraiment qu'on a
oublié claude pichois qui jouent à la
main peu et grier de clôture du sadi
neige a été levée le cdh inès et le sexe
de la femme
voilà quand il est connu et d'envoyer
une façon agréable quand quand la
personne n'est pas agréable on dit une
chose beaucoup plus simple qu'on dit
encore aujourd'hui et le chargement
quand je sais ça dîner c'est plutôt un
compliment directement contenu dans le
mot lambour eux c'est le bourreau c'est
le bourreau quelqu'un qui était griffé
ça surtout ça très joli hein mais
servent qu'a dit bien ses griffes et
donc il est pris mais il est arrêté il
est arrêté par le parquet c'est vraiment
une grive qui s'est abattue ce qui m'a
étonné c'est que vous employez par
exemple l'expression aller tirer la
queue du diable on dit aujourd'hui tirée
à guillaume c'est parce qu'on n'a pas
d'argent
et à part la queue alors on a renversé
la mais on l'a perdu le sens de ces
expressions brimont on l'a perdue dans
sa vie dont dire mourir oui oui là là
qu'on a gardé la garder pour dire tirer
le diable par la queue qui était une
noce
métaphysique une notion qui ont contenu
la mort on en fait tout simplement que
j'imagine que dans ce monde plus plus
sécurisés ne plus avoir les moyens de
bible conduit à la mort aussi mais par
des moyens plus long vous avez remarqué
raymond castans et que dans le midi ont
dit pas un copain on dit un copain et là
on ne pense pas les compagnies comme un
jour moi je ne parlais pas très loin de
chez moi la recette
moi j'ai ce qui m'a beaucoup plu dans ce
bouquin c'est sa truculence sa force de
force des mots le le côté paillard tout
ça c'est leur côté rabelaisien il faut
dire des pourtant avec un désespoir que
n'avait pas forcément pour seulement
j'ai trouvé que des espoirs a été très
bon et est tout à fait évident dans ce
livre parce que trouve certes mais le
bonheur dure peut vous montrer
immédiatement un homme qui reprend la
fuite qui est chassé et poursuivie sans
arrêt vous nous montrez ensuite avec des
jambes torses un corps littéralement
torture et on se demande même où il
prend en charge 10 ans avec un corps
aussi torturé je pense qu'il apprend
beaucoup dans la tête parce que je pense
qu'il n'a jamais été aussi heureux
qu'avec mac dalhem qui a été plus être
violé par d'autres personnes mais qui
n'avait jamais vu d'autres non je suis
pas sûr que le viol de magal n ai eu
lieu ni même que madeleine est vécu
puisque ce soit bien fait quand même je
pense qu'on pourrait pas prendre en
défaut les quatre dates où les quatre
événements que l'on sait de lui
le reste des barons trois peut-être
d'autres manuscrits plus tard qui seront
visées a pensé qu'on ne saura jamais ce
qui est advenu de lui après cette
fameuse 6 janvier cadence entre je
souhaite que les organismes
je souhaite que l'on est ce que c'est
pas une trace qui lui ressemble c'est
pas quelque chose qui nous permet à
chacun d'entre nous d'avoir notre vie
nous oui mais là par claude pichois où
il fait tout contraire ils essayent ils
trouvent tous les symboles l'air presque
jour par jour lui
oui ça fait qu'on n'aura plus le droit
d'avoir que le sien c'est vrai voilà
mais si vous faites un métier différent
du lin lin recettes par par mensonges et
voilà paré étaient là par vérité c'est
de ce sont des méthodes de recherche oui
mais les époques ne sont pas les mêmes
c'est la folie il faut y arriver vous
vous auriez été impardonnable de ne pas
tout dire et moi je et moi j'aurais été
impardonnable de prétendre savoir plus
con c'est alors j'ai dit c'est que
michel